before we get started with the video I
want to quickly thank our patrons over
on patreon
especially our pro tier patrons
including a 17 F FTP Keylong and the one
and only Gilgamesh if you like what we
do and it gives you a value consider
supporting us for as little as $1 a
month over on patreon link in the
description and your name will even be
featured in future videos among these
amazing people right here
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
raking the seven cents from weakest to
strongest using the most current
information we have available in the
manga right now make sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos and suggest future videos you
would like to see in the comments just a
quick warning there will be manga
spoilers in this video you've been
warned
I also want to say that each of the sins
is useful in his or her own way and that
some weaker sins might be more useful in
certain situations than some stronger
ones for instance go thir was useful in
that he could enter into miles mind and
help save him while no one else could
even though he wasn't the strongest and
present my point is all the sins are
valuable and have their moments but this
list will specifically be focused on
power now let's jump into it in last
place we got a man who recently lost his
Opie power it hurts me to say this but I
am of course referring to Eskin or never
fear I will share my thoughts on Eskin
or in the one mode and where he would
rank later on in this video but right
now in the manga Eskin or gave his
sunshine ability to mile and so he is
easily the weakest of the seven deadly
sins without his power
ESCA nor has likely reverted to his
Midnight's strength level which is just
15 even hawks base level is SS canora's
at 30 that doesn't only make esken or
the weakest of the seven deadly sins it
also makes him the weakest holy night in
fact back in chapter 106 we are told
that according to the country standards
to be a holy night in lioness you need
to have a combat class of over 300 so s
Kannur in his current form wouldn't even
get close to making the cut the good
news for o-p-s Kannur fans is that mild
didn't want to take the grace at first
and only agreed after askin or suggested
that he borrow it instead of taking it
thus it is implied that mild will give
the power back to escrow at some point
in the future but for now we got a leave
s Kannur in dead last for the fun of it
though like i said later on i will talk
about s Kannur in the one mode
specifically and how he would measure up
against the other sins next we have go
third go through at first was measured
to have a power level of 3100 which is
pretty good for a doll after he regains
his memory
his power level shoots up all the way to
thirty five thousand four hundred in
Chapter 280 go thir in the presence of
the end realizes that his chances of
victory against the end at this point
are four percent
Deanna's in her weaker human side state
and go thirst ill only has a
ridiculously small chance of being her
and only a 36 percent chance of
successfully getting away albeit it is
only after this chase that Gotha regains
his memories and along with them his
true power but even so this scene
suggests that go through could not have
defeated the end even if he used the
sacred treasure and his invasion ability
furthermore DeeAnn can become
significantly stronger still as we'll
see later on I will mention that goal
third does have a kind of self-destruct
device inside him in Chapter 279 we
figure out that using magic from Eskin
or sunshine as a base adding to it the
four great chemical elements of
destruction and then further taking it
to its absolute limit of power with
Merlin's infinity this self-destruct
device is able to obliterate any and all
living matter in a ten-mile radius from
Goethe er however we've never actually
seen this attack used and the fact I go
through would kill himself in the
process ensuring he wouldn't win the
fight sort of makes the attack pointless
when it comes to strength we want
someone who can win a fight not hope to
get a draw by self-destructing besides
it does not even go through his own
original power but power he borrowed
from s Canora Merlin so for these
reasons despite how devastating this
attack could potentially be I couldn't
place go there any higher on this list
following go through we had Deann in
Chapter 237 chandler measures deeanne's
power level to be 8,000 this is weaker
than go Thurs but this is the anne's
based power level and she can actually
drastically increase her power level by
performing drawls dance according to the
character guidebook
DeeAnn can bring her power level up to
50,000 with trolls dance this would put
her power levels significantly above go
Thurs pal level of 30 5400 furthermore
as we previously seen when go through
calculated that he only had a 4% chance
of beating the an his sacred treasure
and his invasion magic are not good
enough to make up for a significant
difference in combat class add to this
the fact that she's an earthbender and
that she can use the ability heavy metal
to further increase her defensive and
offensive capabilities and you can see
why I had to put her above Goethe her
the warhammer Gideon is worth mentioning
- it weighs 2,200 pounds so you can bet
it packs quite the punch it also has the
ability lightning rod which allows
gideon to absorb magical attacks and
redirect them into the earth
Diann uses this ability in chapter 280
to save her and her friends from one of
miles powerful attacks for all these
reasons the and desert to be this high
on the list after the giant Deanne we
have the sexy Merlin the only recorded
power level we have for her is 4710 but
Merlin has shown that you cannot judge
her based on that combat class she has
the power of infinity which is so
valuable that the demon king and supreme
deity both wanted to recruit her to
their sides Merlin can stop her own time
using infinity which stops her from
aging she says in Chapter 191 that no
matter how powerful a magic all you need
to do is to invoke it once then you can
keep a flame burning keep ice frozen and
keep time still so with infinity Merlin
can keep a spell going indefinitely
until she decides to cancel it in
addition to this opie original magic
power
she got gifts from the demon king and
the supreme deity the demon king gave
her detailed information on all the
secret arts and mysteries of the
underworld and divine protection that
could defend against the brainwashing of
the goddesses while the supreme deity
gave her divine protection able to
nullify any and all manner of dark
curses and commandments despite the fact
that she was only a child she was smart
and powerful enough to trick the two
gods into giving her gifts and get away
safely without joining either of them
our current Merlin has 3000 more years
of wisdom and experience than that
gifted child who tricked the gods
because she doesn't age she can continue
to get wiser acquire new spells and get
more powerful as time goes on if this
wasn't enough reason to put Merlin over
dee Ann then the fact that she was able
to get the better of Cusack who had a
power level of at least 168,000 and
Chandler who had a power level of at
least 173,000 makes it clear that she is
stronger than the Anne Merlin pushed it
to enough so that they decided to
Jews back into their original form the
form of the center aka the original
demon at this point though Merlin knows
that she doesn't have a chance anymore
upon seeing the original demon she says
that they've completely lost all chance
of victory
luckily a stronger sin comes to the
rescue next up we have king who unlocked
his new form with its fully grown wings
and stylish hair with four commandments
absorbed miles power level is set to be
over two hundred thousand he is
absolutely wrecking the end go third
king and everyone present in this form
even a combined attack from the end go
Thor and King doesn't work against it
things look extremely bad for the team
until King unlocks is new for with its
full-grown wings at this point as
gloxinia predicted he would king has
become the strongest fairy king in all
of history even when his wings just
started sprouting King was able to draw
out almost the same power as gloxinia
from his spirit spear with his full
grown wings King is on a whole nother
level in this form King can easily read
thoughts which can definitely come in
handy in fights also in this form not
only is King able to shield the ant and
Elizabeth from mile he is able to attack
mile at the same time King effortlessly
overpowers mile in this form he is so
confident in his abilities to defeat him
again and again if he needs to that he
is even willing to spare miles life
after King overpowers him Maya reaches
his limit once his physical and magical
energy are completely spent he begins to
get devoured by the ten commandments
luckily Gotha enters miles mind and
saves him before that happens
thus at this point it is clear that
Kings power level is well over 200
thousand because he stopped mile who was
already above 200 thousand without
breaking a sweat I don't want anyone
saying that King only one because mile
was being weakened by the ten
commandments it is only after his
physical and magical energy are spent
which happens after King clearly
overpowers him that the commandments
really begin to devour mile before this
point he was absolutely crushing
everyone so King deserves credit for
being able to easily defeat an opponent
with a power level over two hundred
thousand and now we come to the point
where the original demon appears
Merlin says that her team lost all
chance of winning as the original demon
is completely overpowering s Canora
Merlin the spirit spear chasta folk
comes rushing into the scene and stops
the original demon in his tracks
the original demon even recognizes Kings
power as a tremendous energy that's
approaching from afar this is quite the
compliment since remember that he told s
kannur in the same chapter that he's
disappointed that after his midday peak
s Kannur has little to offer in terms of
a challenge keep in mind this is king
using the spirit spear from a distance
so it's not even at full power it even
appeared like Kings long distance attack
sunflower might have done some serious
damage to the original demon maybe even
finished him off but Zell just cancelled
out his attack using the demon Kings
power cell Justin begins fighting the
spirit sphere so that the original demon
can focus on the others still the fact
that the spirit sphere from a distance
could not only keep the original demon
distracted but forces eldress to come to
his rescue shows how strong King has
become if we simply add cous acts and
Chandler's power levels together we get
three hundred and forty-one thousand in
my view that's a low estimate of what
the original demons power level is at
this point and surprisingly enough King
is still a match for him even though he
is fighting from a long distance and as
a result does not have full access to
the spirit Spears power so after the
show of strength
anyone who previously thought that King
with his full grown wings could not have
taken on an opponent over a para level
of 200000 was clearly wrong about that
as we've seen King with his full grown
wings could take on a much stronger
opponent next up in second place we have
bond I did a whole video about how
strong bond is after purgatory so you
can check that out if you want a very
detailed answer to that question I'll
put the link of that video in the
description here I'll summarize some of
the main points I brought up in that
video bond for a long time was one of
the weakest sins but after purgatory he
is easily one of the strongest in fact
some of you are probably thinking that
he should be above Mele Otis now but
I'll let you know later why I decided to
put Mele Otis in first place as I
explained in my how strong his bond
video bonds issue was always his body's
tolerance love
although he used to have an immortal
body and the opie ability snatch his
human body still had a tolerance level
that limited his ability to fully use
snatch velasca points the south which he
realizes that bond cannot absorb all of
gallons power only some of it
despite having an immortal body Vaughn's
body still has to deal with the
consequences of overusing snatch after
he uses it to escape from gallon and
molasse cola he has over exerted his
body to the point that he isn't even
able to lift a single finger however
after spending over a thousand years in
purgatory with its harsh conditions
Vaughn's body's tolerance has
dramatically increased
Meli oldest points out that bonds
experience of enduring and adapting to
purgatory has caused an explosive
transformation upon his body and soul he
ensures him that everyone will be
shocked when they see how much he's
powered up the key here is that bonds
body has not only gotten stronger his
new superhuman tolerance level is going
to let him snatch more power from others
and store it in himself bonds power is
insane now while King Mile with sunshine
Merlin and the others couldn't do
anything against the demon king bond is
able to surprise the demon king with his
speed he rescues Hawk in the blink of an
eye even surprising the demon king in
the process in Chapter 301 our team
notices that bond is able to go
blow-for-blow with the demon king he is
able to wipe the smile off of the demon
king smug face something that no one
else present could do now it looks like
the demon king has the upper hand when
we find out that bond is not alone and
that the demon king is also fighting
Mele Otis's emotions inside his body
nevertheless the battle just started and
we may see the demon king and bond using
his original magic snatch power up quite
a bit more now in first place we got
Mele Otis for you to better understand
why I put Mele Otis in the number one
spot let's rewind to that conversation
bond and Mele Otis were having in
purgatory in Chapter 270 after Mele
Otis's emotions complement bond on his
new power bond explains that Mele Otis
is the truly powerful he says to Mellie
Otis and I quote having come to
purgatory it's clearer now than ever
you've got some crazy strength the
flames or
ice of purgatory can't leave a scratch
on my immortal body but you left me
these battle scars when you're back in
your body captain you'll be truly
invincible I talked about this in more
detail in my Mele Otis's original power
video but bond is right that Mele Otis
seems to be on a whole nother level
nothing could leave lasting damage on
bonds body not the harsh conditions of
purgatory or fighting a demon king for
over 60 years but Mele Otis was able to
give him that scar he has his immortal
flesh was unable to fully heal from
malleolus pretty tame attack clearly
Mele Otis's power breaks the rules it
can permanently injure immortal flesh it
also allows malleolus to take out an
entire kingdom that was on par with
Leonys and strength in a moment of Wrath
like I said before this act of wiping
out an entire kingdom in the blink of an
eye makes the 1,000 days that the demon
king and supreme deity rain down
destruction on the city of beli a Luwin
look like child's play there's a reason
that the demon king is so obsessed with
Mele Otis and no one else he wants Mele
Otis's body because this specific strong
and youthful body has the potential to
surpass his own the demon king has said
that it has to be Mele oldest because he
is the destroyer or the source of
destruction I believe all this points to
the unbelievable strength Emilio this is
original power we see this power in
action when Mele Otis's emotions
completely take out the demon Kings
right arm even scratching the first
layer of the demon King's skin is a
challenge for wild but Mele Otis is able
to go through his armor skin and bone
with no problem Mele Oda suggests that
now that this power is awakened even
after returning he won't be able to stay
in the human world anymore as we know
mal with sunshine and the new and
improved bond are extremely strong
characters but they have no issue
staying in the human world which
suggests that Mele Otis's power really
is on a whole nother level after using
this power on the demon king Mele Otis
laughs and says it's the first time he's
seen the demon King's panicked face the
demon king completely loses his
composure screaming after him he is so
panicked because he knows that now the
Mele Otis is willing to use his original
power he could potentially beat him thus
even if Mele Otis doesn't end up
absorbing the power of
ten commandments himself after him and
bond inevitably defeat the demon king
which he might he still has this
original power that the demon king
desperately fears and wants for himself
a power that is capable of greater
destruction than even the demon king as
we saw malleolus was able to take out
the demon King's whole arm like it was
nothing and we have yet to see anything
close from bond for these reasons I
think bond is right when he said that
Mele Otis is insanely powerful and that
no one else will be able to defeat him
even bond himself now let's briefly
mention how Eskin oars the one form
would fit into our list so I'm not going
to focus on the many drawbacks like that
it only lasts for one minute that it can
be stopped by blocking out the Sun with
a spell and that it has a huge toll on
the physical body of Eskin or we're just
going to be looking at how the power
that Eskimo reaches during that one
minute will stack up when compared to
the power of the people on this list I
think that there's a specific scene that
can help us out with this let's think
back to when s Kannur was using the one
against zell dress yes s kannur was able
to stop the opie attack ominous nebulae
with a karate chop but interestingly
enough so I'll just was able to keep his
karate chop back with his sword mile
with sunshine dealt with the same attack
way easier when he simply got close
enough he deactivated zelgius attack and
melted his sword something that the one
was unable to do so this would suggest
that mile with sunshine even without
being in the one mode is stronger than
esken or in the one mode yet mile with
sunshine was also no match for the demon
king while bond and Mel Yodas as we've
seen can put up a much better fight so
SK nor even in the one mode would have
to be placed lower than both bond after
purgatory and melio Lotus with his
original power you guys can let me know
how you think the one might fare against
King with full-grown wings in the
comments below and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching remember to smash that like
button if you enjoyed the video if you
haven't subscribe and ring that
notification bell for more seven deadly
sins videos follow us on instagram for 7
essence memes and to participate in
future video polls will have their thank
you to our patrons for their support
especially to our pro hero patrons a
17f FDP ki lawn and the one and only
Gilgamesh if you like this kind of
content and want to support more of it
you can do so by going over to our
patreon link in the description and
pledging as little as a dollar a month
don't forget to check out anime uproar
calm for anime merch including the Eskin
or praise the sun t-shirt and Mele
Otisfield the wrath t-shirt fans our
channel can get a whole 25 percent off
if you use the discount code up 4 or 25
at checkout thank you for all of your
support and until next time see a space
cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]